where we left off in the last video we
were in 1902 1903 and mendelian genetics
had been rediscovered at the turn of the
century and bovary and
sutton independently had proposed the
chromosome theory that the chromosomes
were the location
for where these inheritable factors that
mendel first talked about where they
actually were located but we talked
about in that video that that was just a
theory this was based on some
observations of meiosis and seeing how
chromosomes behaved and they seemed to
behave in in analogous ways to some of
these inheritable factors but they
really didn't have good
cellular proof that chromosomes indeed
were the location for these inheritable
factors and we don't really start to get
that until we start looking at the work
of thomas hunt morgan
now in 1908 he decides to study fruit
flies so why does he want to study fruit
flies have you ever seen a fruit fly
they're very very very small so you
could actually put a ton of fruit flies
in one jar
so that's convenient you oftentimes
don't think about the practical
logistics of science but you could put a
lot in one jar they were actually cheap
and that's another practical concern of
science is you don't always have a lot
of resources to do your work and they
had short lives and they reproduced a
lot so you could very quickly get many
many offspring in many many generations
if you wanted to study how the different
traits were passed on or not passed on
and so he spent some time he started
this in 1908 working with the fruit
flies and he kept breeding them in
search for some type of a mutant trait
in general when you look at when you
look at traits in a species the wild
type let me write this down the wild
type is the one that's typically seen
while the mutant trait is something that
seems unusual and after two years he
finally discovers a mutant trait in his
fruit flies he finds a white eyed male
so this is the white eyed male
right over here he says okay now this is
interesting let me take this white eyed
male and begin to cross it with other
with with well with with the females and
you say well how does this actually
occur well what you do is you take a a
jar full of females and you put the
wide-eyed male in there and then the the
crossing happens
and what was interesting was the
inheritance pattern that he saw for this
white eyed trait
because you have the parent generation
here but then in the f1 generation
all of the females were red-eyed and all
of the males were red-eyed and so just
off of that first generation it wasn't
clear that anything interesting was
going on but then
when we when he crossed these to each
other and i know what some of y'all are
thinking wait aren't they all brothers
and sisters being crossed to each other
well yeah
they're probably half brothers and
sisters if they came from different
different mothers but some of them could
have been brothers and sisters but yes
that's that's what people are talking
about when they're crossing the f1
generation but when they crossed these
with each other he saw a pretty
interesting pattern he saw a three to
one ratio of red eyes to white eyes so
for every four fruit flies he would see
let me let me underline these he would
see three
red eyed
and he would see one wide-eyed
so the wide-eyed the wide-eyed trait
makes a reappearance which in and of
itself is interesting it shows that this
can be passed on genetically and that's
interesting because this was a mutant
that just showed up after he did many
many many many many uh generations of
observations
but what was even more interesting about
this three to one ratio and that three
to one is something that popped up a lot
in mendelian genetics but what was even
more interesting was that he only
observed he only observed the white eyes
in the males in this f2 generation in
this second the second generation of the
crosses right over there
and so you're thinking well why is that
a big deal well he was he was a pretty
astute guy and he says well look if i'm
only seeing it in the males and it's not
like he only got four offspring he was
in the ratio he might have had hundreds
of them but it was in the ratio of of of
two red-eyed females for every one
red-eyed male for every one white-eyed
male and so across these hundreds of in
this in this generation he only observed
the white eyes on the males and he said
maybe this is in some way related to the
chromosome that determines sex
and so what he was able to do is say
well let's just assume that it is let's
assume that that trait that that mutant
allele that mutant variation of the gene
for eye color let's assume it's carried
on the x chromosome
and so the genotype
for that first mutant fly that white
eyed male that he found we could call it
and this is the notation that people
typically use because it because this is
a a gene that we're assuming sits on a
it's sex-linked it sits on a sex
chromosome in this case the x chromosome
the way that you would specify the
genotype of that wide-eyed male is
well on his x chromosome he had the
white variation he had the white allele
the white variation of that gene and
then on his y chromosome he had no
variation for that gene so we assume
that it's only contained on the only on
the x chromosome you've probably heard
of heterozygous or homozygous well this
is a case where you have hemizygos you
only have a version of the allele on one
of your two chromosomes one of the two
that you've gotten from each of your
parents so this would be the genotype
right here of the white eyed male
the genotype for the red eyed female
is specified by
so it's on the x chromosome
and the females have two x chromosomes
just like in the situation for humans so
on each of the x chromosomes we assume
that the females start off with the red
allele and the red allele the notation
is the w plus
w plus and you might say well why don't
we just use the letter r well we could
have but the general convention in in
genetics is to use the letter of the
first mutant type discovered for that
gene and then to use this little plus
type for the wild type so the wild type
is the red eyes and then w which is the
first mutant discovered for this gene is
the first mutant allele that we do so we
name it after that white so
this is the white
uh the white allele and these right here
these represent the red alleles so these
are the genotype of the red-eyed female
and so when you cross that first
generation
well the wide-eyed male he can either if
he's with the he'll either produce sperm
that have the x chromosome in it which
is going to contain the allele or sperm
that have the y chromosome in it which
is not going to contain the allele and
the red-eyed female well they produce
eggs either way either which of these x
chromosomes they contribute they're both
going to have the wild type allele and
we can see how this crosses you could
get an x from both parents if you get an
x from both parents you're going to be
female because you're going to be xx
and each of these females since you've
got one wild type and one mutant type
and the wild type turns out to be
dominant they still show their phenotype
is still red eyes they still have red
eyes but now they are heterozygous
they're heterozygotes they are carrying
the white allele
now the male offspring right over here
well in order to be male they got the y
chromosome from their dad so they're not
able to get that white allele and they
get the red the wild type from their mom
and you could see it here and this is
why all of the males in that first
generation were red they only got one
copy of the allele from their wild type
mother but then what was interesting is
what the crosses that you see in that
next generation if you took these
red-eyed females that we already
established these are all going to be
heterozygotes and so you can see they
have the red allele and
and they have the white allele and you
cross that with red-eyed males you cross
it with red-eyed males what is going to
happen
well the females in this generation in
order to be female you have to get an x
from your mom and your dad and so they
get an x from their dad which has the
which has the
mutant sorry which has the wild type
there the dominant red allele and so
regardless of which one they got from
their mom they're still going to be red
eyed females some of them might be
homozygotes some of them might be
heterozygotes but now we see something
happen interesting happening in the
males
you could have heterozygote male
male flies here
where they got the x
from where they got the the red x from
their mom or you could get the
hemozygous wide-eyed males where they
got the where they got the white allele
the white x from their mom and this is
the exact uh this is this is the exact
observation that morgan made so it was a
very interesting thing that he was able
to see he started breeding these in 1908
he started breeding these flies in 1908
it wasn't until a couple of years that
he finally found that first mutant
white-eyed male and it was in 1910
and 1911 that he publishes these
discoveries in nature and the reason why
this is a big deal is he says look this
is my observations are completely
consistent with this with this i trait
this gene being on the x chromosome so
he was able to show a direct linkage
between in this case sex chromosomes and
these heritable factors that mendel
first talked about and he would go on
and his students that he worked with
would go on to study this for for many
many many many years and he actually
ends up getting a nobel prize for this
work and this is a big deal because he's
finally able to draw pretty substantive
connections between these heritable
factors of gen of mendel this theory of
bover bovary and sutton that maybe
chromosomes have something to do with
these inheritable factors and he's
showing that this is actually the case
these sex chromosomes seem to carry the
trait or in case in this particular case
the x sex chromosome seems to carry the
the gene
for
eye color in these fruit flies